[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
good morning good morning going out of
business sale
that's right put up for some sales sign
the Trump organization is cut down like
a fresh cut tree grounded
oh boy and he's pissed he's super pissed
the people are gonna find out he's
broke
Donald Trump's been broke for a long
time we've known this
this has been coming and this is what
happens when you hire shitty attorneys
and then you have those shitty attorneys
try to make shitty arguments in court
because not only not only is this judge
demanding in that by this quarter within
10 days to dissolve the Trump
organization along with just a slew of
llc's
and it names Donald Trump Donald Trump
Jr Eric Trump ion weiselberg in the
actual
decision here
but he also sanctions his attorneys
because his attorneys were told that you
couldn't make these arguments in court
and they still tried to and the reason
why is because Trump's a [__] idiot
now
the craziest part about all this
and and I I know it shouldn't be
surprising that he's a fraud
we knew that right that's not surprising
it's not surprising that they're gonna
whine and [__] about it
of what they caused
him and his sons and the people who ran
that [__] box organization over there
to defraud not just the state of New
York but
separate Banks
other municipalities
it's fraud it's fraud no matter how you
shake it it's fraud
and it was on a mass scale
but here's the thing here's the craziest
part to me
this morning I decided you know what I'm
gonna see what the media is saying about
this because I've been trying to keep
track of what the [__] they're saying
and this morning the media was like
Donald Trump
has to dissolve his business in New York
and this is horrible for Joe Biden I'm
like what in the actual [__] are you
talking about
literally the politics talk around this
this morning in the mainstream media is
how this is bad for Joe Biden I'm not
kidding you that's how they're well let
me tell you how they're framing it which
is [__] Wild
it's wild stuff they're like oh
I and and I've been telling you I've
been telling you
I know you some don't believe me I know
some are still on the fence about this
you're gonna get there because
it's exactly what they're doing you'll
get to the truth eventually
I'm telling you with these polls that
show that it's neck and neck oh it's
neck and neck they want you to think
that this race is close
which it's not even a race at this point
we haven't even gotten to a primary yet
really I mean to be honest we're not
even in the general election cycle
but they want you to believe that this
race is so close between Joe Biden and
Donald Trump
for this very [__] reason
this very [__] reason
they say they say well I can't believe I
can't believe that Donald Trump not only
is charged with 91 felonies in four
different jurisdictions but now he has
to dissolve his entire organization and
Joe Biden still can't beat him that's
what they're saying that's the narrative
I can't believe Trump is under so much
stress and Joe Biden still can't beat
him
that's why they have to have those
stupid [__] poles
that are just ridiculous
because it's all about getting you the
viewer afraid to keep on listening keep
on listening oh boy okay boy
Trump's such a criminal [__] box but Joe
Biden can't beat him because the media
said because the poll said well don't
believe it
folks listen to me listen
they're feeding you shovels of horseshit
and I listened to it this morning on
MSNBC on Morning Joe they were saying it
this was the narrative I can't believe
Donald Trump is in this position but
he's still going to beat Joe Baden now
is there something to be said to not get
people complacent yes but you can't get
people complacent by [__] lying to
them
when you lie to people it breeds
discouragement when you lie to people it
breeds disengagement if you don't
believe me wait to see what happens in
November next year to manga
folks all the lies and all the horseshit
shovel down their throats from for the
last two years and for the next year and
a half they're gonna disengage
I'm telling you
they're going to self-suppress their
vote
it's going to happen
they're gonna say you know what you're
right Trump it's all rigged against you
anyways everything's rigged against you
there's no reason to go vote
[__] doubt me
I'm telling you
it's gonna be it's gonna be hard to get
to get Maga to the polls
and not just Maga
people who are a manga adjacent you know
the ones that want to take advantage of
manga the ones that like manga because
it's all about owning the libs right
but they just don't like to do the manga
thing you know they're just they're just
in it for the affiliation
not really to fly the flags in the back
of their trucks
I'm telling you folks
you cannot take the shovel out of their
hands when they're digging their own
[__] grave
here
it's just something that we don't want
to do
but the mainstream media and it and and
again if anyone on the mainstream media
isn't pointing out that the mainstream
media is failing then they're not part
then they're not part of the good part
of the mainstream media
if they're not speaking out against
their own their own [__] kind here
because this morning the overall
narrative was huh Trump's in big trouble
but you know who's in bigger trouble Joe
badden because he's neck and neck in the
polls that we come up with and we like
and we show you
even though they're all [__]
there's only one poll that matters only
one and that's the ballot that's it the
ballot is the only poll that [__]
matters
why why the media doesn't report on that
when they're like these polls show one
thing but the vote is not showing that
same thing these polls seem to be like
they're full of [__]
seems like we probably need to work up a
different way to do a poll
they're [__] they have been [__]
for a long time
the last time the polls are even close
to being correct was 2016. the popular
vote poll was damn near spot on with
Hillary Clinton that's the last time the
polls are really correct
the last time
I I don't know what to tell you
I mean I I wish we could get decent
polls to get a decent pulse on what the
country's thinking but we can't rely on
that anymore
we have to rely on our own optimism of
democracy and we have to rely on our
work
in the engagement of democracy because
I'm telling you
they're gonna make this I can't believe
it oh man
dudes bitching
that this judge ruled against him what
did he think was going to happen when he
when he wanted a bench trial when he
wanted this judge to decide because you
know that's really the other [__]
narrative here that is getting lost is
that Trump is believing his own [__]
this whole out man oh man well look here
we I just can't get a fair trial
anywhere I can't get a fair trial anyway
he just stopped Trump he's a victim oh
he's a victim he can't get a fair trial
anywhere oh man how's he ever going to
beat this if he can't get a fair trial
he can't get a jury these places he
can't get a change of venue that's
they're believing their own [__]
so they're like yeah what was the judge
decide and when the judge is like [__]
you you committed fraud it's obvious you
committed fraud and then
oh my God so
Mar-A-Lago there's a question of its
value in this in this uh
in this decision so the judge also the
judge did was take the lowest [__]
the lowest appraisal of of Mar-A-Lago
and said well that's the value right
he took the [__] value that they give
it the the most legitimate lowest value
that they give it 18 million bucks
well Trump and his family claim it's
worth a billion dollars I mean Eric
Trump was on Fox I think it was Fox news
last night saying it's worth a billion
dollars
Mar-A-Lago is worth a billion dollars
[__] out of here man
okay but apparently this guy was telling
this guy was
telling banks that it was worth six
seven hundred million or some [__] it's
not even close to that
like let's say you own a house that's
worth I don't know two hundred thousand
dollars right
you know if you got a house or 200 Grand
it depends on where you're at in the
country that might be a small house that
might be a really big house that might
be a dump it just depends on where
you're at in the country where I'm at in
the country it's a pretty nice little
house you know in the midwest in
Missouri yeah it is pretty nice that's
why a lot of people moved to Missouri
because the cost of living here is
nothing compared to other places
compared comparatively
still you know it's still not cheap but
the point is this is that if you add a
200 000 house this should be like you
going to the bank and trying to convince
them that your house is worth like 300
million dollars
to say that it's worth 18 million to 1
billion come on you you [__] who the
[__]
how in the hell can they
convince these people of this trash
just go look up Mar-A-Lago see where
it's at how big it is what it actually
is how old it is that thing ain't worth
near a billion dollars get the [__] out
of here
man
look at other real estate in the area it
doesn't take a genius to go figure this
[__] out
but they know that they're not gonna go
figure that out right
because honestly they don't have a
choice here
they don't have a choice this is it I
mean they're going to appeal this for
sure
for sure
but them
he ain't going to win this
it was obvious fraud I mean the judge is
sanctioning his attorneys for trying to
make the goddamn argument that they told
them not to make you can't make that
argument that's not an argument you can
make in court and they still tried
because Trump's a little [__]
because that's honestly the the
look
folks
he's not a businessman he's a fraud he's
never been a good businessman the dude
had a silver spoon okay
a gold spoon [__]
and it was huge and it had mounds of
sugar piled on top of it when it was
stuffed in his mouth when he was born
If he if Donald Trump really would have
been a good businessman he would have
taken what his dad gave him what he
inherited and the do would be worth 40
50 billion dollars at this point he
doesn't even claim to be worth what he
should be worth
what he should be worth if he was a good
business person okay this guy has gone
bankrupt time and time again
I told I've been telling you for [__]
months almost a year that he's gonna
lose his business and they have it in
receivership
people thought I was they're like oh no
that's all [__] no I'm telling you
when they put the fraud charges on Trump
organization and then tis James filed
this civil suit that's it it was done
Trump organization was done
and then that dumb [__] tried to
tried to transfer assets out of his New
York businesses because he knew it was
done
he knew it was gonna go away he knew
this was going to happen
he was trying to transfer assets and
when he did that Tish James stopped him
in his tracks and a judge put his entire
business under receivership that is why
they know what they know and why he's
only giving him 10 [__] days to get
this thing uh in in
in some sort of hands of people who can
manage to sell this business over time
now it's not going to be like overnight
they take the words Trump Tower down off
that stupid [__] building in
Manhattan but they're going to
they're [__] they're they're gonna take
the name off that building on Fifth
Avenue
did this to himself by the way
this is not something where he's the
victim of
this guy has done this [__] for decades
and decades and decades and no one has
ever held him accountable not a bank not
a [__] government
he stole from the people of New York he
stole their [__] money
this is the other thing we got to get
through our thick [__] skulls here is
that the billionaire oligarchy class in
this country
the the plutocracy in this country is
stealing our money
got it they're stealing our [__]
money
I don't give a [__] how you spin it how
you want it they're stealing our Goddamn
money
why do you think the uaws
strike is going so well
they're gonna get what they want why do
you think the UPS strike worked they got
what they want
the writers sag
on and on it goes and every single
[__] worker in this country should
strike if they can and pick it if they
can [__] them [__] these goddamn
billionaires [__] this goddamn ruined
class in this country [__] them
and anyone who thinks they are them who
aren't them yes there are people out
there that you know who think that
they're rich or gonna be rich one day
and they're not
that's the whole [__] that's another
big lie that's been told in this country
since the 1980s that somehow you're
gonna be a billionaire someday
what the [__] are you talking about
you're gonna be a billionaire how
how are you gonna be rich and when they
convince people that they convince them
that that they should lower taxes on the
rich and you oh you can't hurt them job
creators job creators get the [__] out
of here
the people who work at them plants at
Ford Chevrolet
and Chrysler are the job creators
you son of a [__] how the hell do you
think Chevrolet or Ford or Chrysler is
going to sell cars if they don't have
people to build them huh
and if they don't have people to buy
them
if people aren't making enough [__]
money in this country don't have a
decent [__] wage
how in the [__] are you gonna how in the
[__] are you gonna say that that GM is
the job Creator [__] you
[__] you
we learned this [__] during the pandemic
it's one it's one of the silver linings
of what happened to this country when we
had to decide in this country who was an
essential worker and what that [__]
meant
it's one of the Silver Linings that
happened and I know that sounds gross
but hey folks I'll take whatever we can
get
to get to to a place in this country
where we can tell the rich oligarchy in
this country to [__] off
[__] you this is not your money this is
not your money
you got all the big money and you got
all the capital and you people can run
the businesses but we're gonna get our
[__] fair share here and you're gonna
pay your [__] fair share
Donald Trump took took advantage of the
state of New York's infrastructure the
entire time took advantage of the
state's government
you don't think so you don't think
running those businesses
he used
taxpayer dollars
and infrastructure that the taxpayers
had to protect him and to protect his
businesses what about the firefighters
what about the the police what about the
city planners the city Engineers huh
what about all that [__] that the state
of New York and the City of New York and
the county pay for huh
and Donald Trump [__] robbed them
Rob them Blind by not paying his [__]
fair share that he owed
which left the people of the state of
New York to [__] foot the bill
[__] these sons of [__] [__] the [__]
the [__] up there at the big three
that don't want to give the UAW their
money [__] the streaming Platforms in
the Hollywood Studios that don't want to
give people their [__] fair share
people deserve a decent [__] wage in
this country
for these people
out there deluded by this fool
and not seeing that he defrauded the
state of New York so that he didn't have
to pay his fair share in taxes which
only meant that the people in New York
the state of New York had to foot the
bill
[__] you you sons of [__] you're not
fair workers Trump is not no [__] he
is he is an anti he is an anti-worker
oligarch
the anti-worker oligarch I'm going to
show you [__] evidence that he hates
unions
anyone anyone who's a member of the
[__] Union
and really anyone who benefits from
anything the union has has ever given
this country which is a 40-hour work
week [__] weekends
did you know that did you know did you
know the reason why you get Saturday and
Sunday off
it's because of of unions
do you know what where the 40-hour work
week came from um uh let's see unions
where do you think that [__] came from
huh
I I mean you may not be a a union member
you may not be a card carrier hell you
might not be a big fan of the Union
I don't I don't know
but if you're against the Union
you're against workers
and Trump's always been against workers
he's not for them he's against them
and he will continue to be
and the media really trying to paint
this up that oh well he's trying to
appear to be pro-worker well you're
trying you're trying to appear media
to to capitulate to the [__] lies
it's really easy for the media to say
well Trump is lying when he says he's
pro-worker because he's not
he's not
never has been never will be he'll lie
to him oh he'll [__] lie to workers
oh [__] he loves to do that why doesn't
the media report on that how he lies to
workers
instead of just saying well the trip
campaign really wants to be pro-worker
they're saying he's pro-worker
I'm just glad he's going out of business
[Laughter]
oh that's the big story today and
tomorrow and the next day it will
continue he's going to continue to lose
his mind and as he loses his mind we
will stay with it every single step of
the way because we will mock him until
the day he dies here on the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific do not forget to go to
the Tony michaels.com that's right go to
thetonymichaels.com hit subscribe at the
top you're not going to want to miss a
single notification oh well look I need
to refresh the page there it is Boom
we've got the brand oh no what the hell
I I did it wrong you notice this see
that the title has not changed oh man I
messed this up I messed this up I gotta
fix it I'm sorry I just gotta fix it
I can't let this go unfixed while we're
live here on the air I know it kind of
gets me um out of my groove here but
we're gonna fix it watch see watch how
fast this is when I fix it I'm gonna get
the title right and the episode right
boom there it is Trump is out of
business at the very top you can find
the episode every single weekday at the
very top and also buy me Shots it's
Wednesday it's going to be karaoke night
don't forget to buy some shots maybe
I'll make a video tonight of doing some
shots and put it on the Discord oh you
can send me a venmo super chat I want to
thank everyone who's bought me shots and
sent a venmo super chat over the last
few weeks that's how you support this
show I could not keep this microphone on
without you and also considering that
maybe you should go check out the
patreon page we're having a lot of fun
uh on the Discord in the morning if you
join patreon
you can go check out the 20 tier you
will be able to join me on Mondays and
Fridays for the early morning show The
Producers corner where we have
conversations about all the news going
on what's going to happen during the
show I have conversations with you
directly that's right you can talk to me
directly right there in the producers
corner on Discord so go to
patreon.commichaels or go to
thetonymichaels.com select the patreon
link there go visit that twenty dollar
tier and you will be able to join us on
Discord in the mornings on Monday and
Friday an hour before the show an hour
before the show you will be able to join
us
I appreciate all your guys's support it
means so much to me uh one other piece
of business that I want to get to we've
got a lot of people who've signed up for
the moderator uh consideration here it
is right here on the Tony michaels.com
the form is right here if you did sign
up for that which we're starting to go
through those so if you're hearing me
and you signed up for that go back in
there and give us your handles for each
platform so we know which platform you
have your handle on so we can identify
you in other words so go in there give
us what platforms you're on and your
handles on those platforms so we can
identify you we're going through that
list right now as we currently speak
also you know why I'm here
on the screen
speaking of moderators and places to
moderate
we're looking for some twitch moderators
uh but twitch if you have an Amazon
Prime account did you know that you
could link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account and that gives us a
few dollars here on the show and it
doesn't cost you a single extra dime
that's right when you have an Amazon
Prime account you get one free
subscription on Twitch through Amazon
gaming you can give us that one
subscription that you get with Amazon
Prime through twitch you just all the
directions are right here on the Tony
michaels.com just click link Amazon and
twitch it shows you exactly how to give
us that subscription with your Amazon
Prime account which keeps the show going
and keeps us supported like I said
you're the shareholders of the show
you're the you you keep this microphone
going I could not keep this microphone
phone on without you the audience
and as the audience and as the
microphone funder
stick around because I'm gonna be
yelling and screaming into the
microphone today
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around through the break don't
forget to hit that subscribe button here
if you're on YouTube you're not going to
want to miss a single episode of this
show live live live every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 with Civic on YouTube Facebook
and twitch
right
all the major platforms live live live
every single weekday
oh boy and Donald Trump's in trouble
isn't he or is he not I don't know I
mean
seems like um he really believes that
he's going to win this
he maybe he doesn't I I can't really
tell I can't tell what kind of [__]
he believes in what kind of [__] he
doesn't anymore I mean he used to be
predictably unpredictable and he's still
you know pretty predictable on his
responses and of course you know this
morning he's really he's really pissed
off that they're gonna like strip him of
him pretending to be wealthy I mean
that's really what it is more than
anything
I mean here's here's the here's the
statement if you want to see it oh no
that's not it
let me switch switch it back here
oh there it is so here is um here's his
statement
about the
about the decision there in New York he
says I have a deranged Trump hating
judge it seems like every judge he get
is deranged and Trump hating hmm
it's almost like when you commit crime
it's almost like when you can make crime
judges don't like that kind of [__]
isn't it it's
who railroaded this fake case
through the NYS Court
as a speed never seen before
you know it sounds like shouldn't he be
happy about that he's like it was it was
a great trial a great case so fast it
went so fast we didn't go slow we went
so fast he's so mad this went fast
he's pissed
that this went fast it took a year to
get here
I think I think tis James announced last
September
that she was going to file this lawsuit
against him this civil suit and it took
a whole year to get to this point
and one reason why we're at this point
so fast is because of trump not this in
spite of him
because of him
[__] out of here man
he says and this is again I don't show
his statements a lot anymore but this
one this one in particular is um oh man
it's
it's great he says you're refusing to
let it go let it go to a commercial
division where it belongs denying me
everything no trial no jury hey dummy
hey dummy your [__] attorneys
requested this
so which is it can you not get a fair
jury or do you or do you get pissed when
you request not a jury
what a [__] bonehead
he made up the crazy kill Trump I love
that kill Trump oh man he's really
trying to he's trying hard to make make
people think that you know somehow he's
gonna be assassinated you remember when
when Tucker Carlson asked him this [__]
are you scared of being assassinated
assigning insanely low values to
properties that's what you were doing
when you were paying taxes despite
overwhelming evidence as an example he
values the most spectacular property in
Palm Beach Florida Mar-A-Lago at 18
million when it's worth possibly a
hundred times that amount
a hundred times that amount dude
you [__] have brain damage I mean
just absolute [__] brain damage if
you think that Mar-A-Lago is worth over
a billion are you listening
a billion
with a [__] B this guy thinks that
that [__] [__] Golf Course
in South Florida
is worth a billion dollars he is outside
his [__] mind
and so is Eric Trump on this I'm going
to show you a clip later
his anger and hatred is politically
motivated
and unprecedented by those who watched
my actual net worth is much greater
than the numbers shown on the financial
statements uh oh
uh oh so you're saying you lied on the
financial statements hmm and a big
surprise to him in the racist AG
letitious games there she go there he
goes doing the whole reverse of racism
thing who campaigned for office on the
get Trump platform I like that
while murderers roam the sidewalks of
New York my banks are happy are they
though all loans are current and paid
off in full sometimes early with no
defaults or problems of any kind there
is also an ironclad disclaimer clause
none of that is [__] true
none of it
that's why I tell you I think the best
part about this whole thing is he
believed this [__] about the jury
like he's he starts to [__] believe
his own [__] like look at this
in this statement he's like no trial no
jury
well you can't have it both ways Grandpa
you can't say that I don't I can't get a
fair jury and then [__] when you when
you request not a jury because you can't
get a full [__] because you can't
what are you talking about
come on man decide make a decision be
for something or be against it
or come up with a different [__] plan
would you please
and really honestly this kind of
insanity is exactly what we need like
he's flailing folks
flailing
he is he is absolutely built an entire
universe around him that is all 100
built on lies
and it is all crashing down upon upon
Him here's a report from Scott mcfucker
Donald Trump launched his political
career saying he'd mastered the art of
the deal the judges ruled Trump inflated
some of his net worth and some of those
deals
a judge has found Donald Trump engaged
in fraud over inflating the worth of his
real estate holdings and misleading
Banks and insurers the ruling comes days
before the Trump organization is to
stand trial in a civil case alleging
years of Fraud and misconduct brought by
New York attorney general Leticia James
last year claiming you have money that
you do not have
does not amount to the art of the deal
it's the art of the steel
in the ruling the judge found Trump and
top Executives at the Trump organization
lied about his assets in order to secure
favorable loans and lower insurance
premiums in one instance claiming his
ten thousand square foot apartment was
roughly 30 000 square feet the judge
summarizing Trump's approach to
bookkeeping this is a fantasy world not
the real world
ah so the judge didn't even believe that
Donald Trump lives in reality like even
the judge in his decision is like you're
you're [__] you're out of your
goddamn gourd
you're
you're out you lost your marbles no he
didn't lose his marbles the marbles
packed their [__] and [__] left hey
George I'm out of here get your [__]
we're getting the hell out of here even
the judge knows
that Donald Trump is not well
this is a fantasy world not the real
world
that's the judge's decision here
wild stuff keep going the lawsuit from
Attorney General James seeks a quarter
of a billion dollars and there cannot be
different rules for different people in
this country or in this state
and former presidents are no different
when Trump was deposed in the case in
August of last year he pleaded the fifth
and then repeated it more than 400 times
same answer
same answer same answer okay so again
again this is more of Trump's doing
right this is more of Trump's doing now
I wanna I wanna say something here and
the reason why because I'm going to
continue the report here
because it kind of rampant in a bow
because you know he's he's in he's a
lunatic
but you know what significant about
the decision from the judge is that
the judge decides Donald Trump Donald
Trump Jr Eric Trump and Alan weissenberg
he names them on the decision but
somehow
somehow did you notice that there's
someone kind of missing
did you notice that there's someone
missing from this decision that was part
of the Trump Organization for many years
did you notice that hmm I don't know
maybe you'll catch on to who who it was
we'll go over here in a bit Trump has
repeatedly denied wrongdoing and lashed
out at James for bringing the suit this
raging Maniac campaigned for office
ranting and raving about her goal her
only goal is we got to get Donald Trump
we're going to get him she knew nothing
about me I never heard of her you know
prosecutors don't really normally want
to get to know the people that they're
Prosecuting and they don't have to know
the people that they're breastfeeding
like they that's kind of part of the
system they don't have to know they
don't have to know and nor do the people
being prosecuted have to know who the
prosecutors are that's kind of a thing
too
in a statement to CBS News a trump
spokesperson calls the ruling
fundamentally flawed the judges also
ordered sanctions of some of Trump's
attorneys Nora saying some of their
arguments were quote frivolous
some of their arguments were quote
frivolous now that's quite the
understatement
of the century isn't it
oh my gerd
oh my gerd it's just it's it's a
beautiful beautiful situation for Trump
to be in honestly this is oh boy oh man
he whoo baby he he couldn't he couldn't
appear to be more for the American
worker in this moment than when he's
defrauding and claiming that he's part
of the billionaire class
yeah like you understand that right like
this guy wants to be part of the
oligarchy more than anything else on
Earth he's always wanted people to
believe that he's rich and famous
now he's broken infamous
so congratulations Grandpa
congratulations fatso
congratulations poopy pants
the Q Anon the Q Anon cult really
delivered you
to your to your ultimate goal here rich
and famous broke and Infamous [__] that
guy now I want to show you commercial
though
it vipes back against this messaging uh
and they're finally starting to catch
you on here this is a pretty good ad
watch this says he stands with Auto
Workers but as president Donald Trump
passed tax breaks for his rich friends
while automakers shuttered their plants
and Michigan lost manufacturing jobs Joe
Biden said he'd stand up for workers and
he's delivering passing laws that are
increasing wages and creating good
paying jobs manufacturing is coming back
to Michigan because Joe Biden doesn't
just talk he delivers
I'm Joe Biden and I approve this message
Joe Biden just doesn't talk he delivers
now this is a direct punch to Trump and
it's all [__] true every bit of it
now I wish they would have included this
clip or a couple of these clips in in
what this is against uh in this ad in
Michigan uh where a large population of
UAW workers live and reside okay
um I wish they would have played part of
this clip on Fox news now this is back
in 2008 when we had the last strike you
remember you remember when the Auto
industry in this country went to the
government they're like look we're gonna
[__] drown We're not gonna have an
auto industry if if you don't step in
and help us they're like Yeah well yeah
and the union the UAW is even like okay
we'll help you we'll we'll freeze raises
we'll make sure that we keep you alive
so that way
we can work another day right they did
that for for the big three the UAW did
and now they're asking for their fair
share now that the Auto industry is back
cracking right it's a banger right now
but this was Donald Trump back back when
the [__] Auto industry was begging
for [__] welfare from the government
Barack Obama delivered on that made sure
that they paid us our [__] money back
in the UAW took concessions but this is
how Donald Trump felt about it in that
moment listen to how he felt about UAW
workers and unions in general
I think that the unions are really
really hurting very badly what's going
on with the auto
is hurting the Auto industry does he huh
it seems
seems here let's take another clip from
that interview let's see how he really
does feel about people getting their
fair share workers that is the people
who keep the profits in the pockets of
the big three let's see what this
[__] thought
about them getting their fair share I oh
I bet I bet it's gonna show that he's
Pro worker huh yeah I bet it's what's
going to show huh manga let's listen I
mean everything it's years and years of
deep City and you know I see it in my
own company
well my company is a lot newer over the
years we have Christmas bonus time right
and we've done well
now
I pay somebody a bonus 20 years ago can
you give them a little more a little
more a little more now it's 20 years
later all of a sudden I'm saying I'm
paying them too much
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait so
you're so [__] successful
now this morning he wants us to believe
that he's so successful and he's worth
all this money but even back in 2008
when the when this country was
struggling when his workers were
struggling he thought I'm paying you his
workers he's paying his workers this is
what he's saying about the people who
[__] work for him
and you think he you think he gives a
[__] about the common common average
American who who works their ass off
rather in an office or in a factory
you think he gives a [__] about them
blue collar billionaire my [__] ass
you [__] moglodytes this this is more
[__] disgusting than your [__]
belief about stolen [__] elections
you pieces of trash he shits all over
you [__] and has his entire
life he doesn't give a [__] about you or
what you do to [__] make a living in
this country not a goddamn [__] as he
give honestly he wants to exploit your
[__] labor so that he can appear to
be a [__] oligarch you pieces of
[__] [__] do you want to know why our
country set back [__] 50 years
because you dumb [__] believe
these billionaires [__] lies
you pieces of [__] trash any one of
you that are on the side of any [__]
billionaire anywhere and not the workers
Europe you were unfucking American
period
Un-American period [__] you
listen to this [__] piece of trash
again this isn't this isn't this
[__] being the president this
[__] this is him acting like
he's a goddamn billionaire remember what
he's doing here on this [__]
interview he's on Fox News
trying to [__] pretend to be a
goddamn oligarch and listen to how he
[__] feels
I'm paying up too much I mean I'm paying
some guys much more than I should be
paying you know why Time same thing with
the unions to get a little increase get
another another year guys
no I just give them bonuses but you know
I always like I know it's not a hickory
cheese oh man oh my god oh man time is
what has done it to them the more time
goes on the more I gotta pay these
[__] because you know I don't
know like inflation and [__]
this [__] believed in 2008 that
the people who work for him should make
the same amount that they made 40
[__] years ago while he raked in all
the Goddamn money
and you're gonna defend this
[__] you're gonna make this
[__] that the nominee of your
party you made him the president United
States union members listen to me listen
to me you [__] the union members
voted for this son of a [__]
because of Lies
lies this is how he really feels in this
interview
when he's telling you he's pro-worker
and when the media is telling you that
his campaign is trying to appear to be
pro-worker they are [__] feeling you
full of just truckloads of horse [__]
this guy has never been [__] Pro
worker ever in his life to be quite
honest he's anti-worker and he's part of
the oligarchy
at least he wants to be
that's what he's trying here on this
Neil Cavuto interview from 2008. why the
[__] doesn't the media play this goddamn
clip when they're talking about Trump in
unions
why and where in the [__] is the UAW
telling Trump to [__] off every [__]
last one of them I don't give a [__]
what their political affiliation
he doesn't like the pores and he thinks
anyone who isn't a billionaire is the
ports I'm not even talking about top
level people I'm talking about you go a
little bit a little bit a little bit a
little bit all of a sudden 20 years is
up and now you're saying man that's a
lot of money I'm sitting behind myself
somebody expects it right they expect
December rolls around I think Don's
going to be good to me you know it's the
same thing with the Unions that's right
they get their little five percent
together
three percent four percent then all of a
sudden they're making more money than
the people that own the company
oh
my God I have to collectively play pay
my Workforce more than I make in one
year
that's literally what he just said
did you hear what the [__] he just said
he just said it is a shame
that I have to pay my Collective
Workforce more than I one person make in
an entire year
now if you're still out there supporting
Donald Trump and you think he he is he
is for the American people you are a
dumb [__]
you are the dumbest piece of [__]
trash that we have in this country
and you are anti you are anti-worker you
are anti-middle class and you were
anti-American
period full stop
if you even consider voting for this son
of a [__]
you are anti you are anti-American you
are not for the working class in this
country you do not give a [__] about
workers you don't give a [__] about
workers pay you don't give a [__] about
making a decent [__] wage and if you
tell me that [__] to my face that you
care about people making a decent wage
and you vote for this piece of trash
[__] out of here with that nonsense I
don't give a [__] if you don't like the
unions
his [__] workers weren't unionized
and he's bitching he's bitching about
paying his low-level workers he even
just told you you only rewind it let's
[__] re-watch it again let's watch it
again because he talks about his upper
level management he's like I'm not
really talking about them watch Pang you
know why Time same thing with the unions
to get a little increase another another
year guys
no I just give them bonuses but you know
I always like I know it's not a hickory
cheese I'm not even talking about top
level people I'm talking about you go a
little bit a little bit a little bit I'm
not even talking about the top level
people oh I give them my top level
people so much money they're they they
deserve it the top level people who help
me commit crime the ones who help me
commit the fraud I definitely give them
[__] money oh they deserve all the
money in the world because they make
sure that I can [__] the little guy oh
and I can [__] the state and I can [__]
the bank that's why they deserve it they
deserve it because I can steal and they
help me steal [__] you buddy how in the
[__] has he convinced anyone that this
son of a [__] is blue collar
have you ever met one [__] Blue
Collar person in your [__] life
that said yeah I I really think those
rich people should get more money yeah
our upper management the upper
management my company thank you so much
for us they should get paid a hundred
times more than me and I shouldn't get
[__] really honestly I'm so [__] lazy
I'm I'm such a [__] piece of trash
I'm one of the Poor's and I shouldn't
deserve any kind of wage really honestly
I should struggle I should struggle
because I'm you know just a worthless
worthless lower middle class person I
definitely should struggle in life I
mean I work 40 hours a week I break my
back for that son of a [__] but it just
ain't enough it just ain't have you ever
heard someone say that in your entire
[__] life
about themselves
and if you have heard them say that [__]
they have [__] for brains
and they're probably not worth four
seconds of your time or attention
and this guys this guy's for the
American people
not one not one [__] who's in
the Union
who knows what the union has done for
them and this country and workers in
this country regardless if they're in
unions or not do you know what's going
to happen when these unions strike over
and over and over again
people are going to get paid more
wages are going to raise
how do you think capitalism works when
they have to compete for a Workforce
and we have to make them compete for our
our [__] labor that's how capitalism
Works make them compete for it even if
we have to collectively bargain for them
to compete for it
use your goddamn brains
and tell everyone you know to use your
goddamn brain and media hey media you
pieces of [__] [__]
whenever you're talking about Trump and
UAW if you don't play this clip you're
doing a dereliction in your duty
full stop 100 if you're watching the
media and they mention Trump and they
[__] mention the UAW and they don't
show you this [__] clip their their
trash turn it off
period their [__] trash turn it off
they're not serious
the media is not serious if they don't
show this clip when they talk about
Trump in the UAW
he's talking about the UAW in this
[__] clip
directly and he says it listen listen to
the end
listen I'll give it to you again
that's right they get their little five
percent they get another two percent
they get another three percent four
percent then all of a sudden they're
making more money than the people that
own the company
huh they're [__] unions they you the
workers the workers all the workers how
[__] egregious that that a company
owner would have to pay his Collective
Workforce more money than he makes just
one person in a year [__] ridiculous
this is his real belief folks
this isn't him campaigning for president
and trying to [__] lie to people
this is him pretending to be the
oligarch that he wants to be
the one that he's claiming he is
on true social last night and this
morning
he's claiming he's [__] wealthy he's
Rich he's Rich Beyond Your Wildest
Dreams which he's not
he's pretending just like he pretended
to be president he's pretending to be
part of the oligarch class in this
country that's what he's that's what
he's desired his entire life
it's because his dad was a piece of rich
white trash
who [__] stole money from the
government
of you know that did you know the Trump
Fortune is built on the backs of uh
what's that called taxpayers did you
know that HUD
a government agency government
regulation government money welfare
that's how Trump is what he is and how
he pretends to be a billionaire today
and all that's come Crashing Down
all of it is coming crashing down on
Trump good [__] them [__] em [__] em
[__] em I wish you know it couldn't
happen to a better guy but I wish it
would happen to much better people in
this country like other billionaires
Elon Musk yeah they all [__] them every
single one of them not a one of them is
good to us anymore
billionaires used to do all kinds of
social work in this country when when
they made profits off the backs of this
country it used to be a thing
Andrew Carnegie gave a [__] ton of money
how even even the Koch brothers if you
want to get down to it the Koch brothers
gave a ton of money
to Arts
they don't do that [__] anymore not
really it's sad it's [__] sad and you
know what since they don't do it anymore
we should just we should [__] take it
from them it's our GDP anyways that's
right it's ours there are way [__]
more of us than there are of them
Eat the Rich [__] them [__] [__] the
three big three if they want to go down
in flames because they don't want to pay
the workers their Fair [__] share of
the GDP and their profits [__] them go
go to hell
same way with the studios and the
goddamn streaming platforms [__] them go
to hell you ain't gonna pay people what
the [__] they're worth and you ain't
gonna pay them their [__] share of
the profit [__] you
and again this is a silver lining from
the [__] pandemic and I've said it
for two goddamn years and they are
starting to confirm it they're like oh
man there's this attitude out here that
these workers that these workers are the
ones who deserve all the appreciation
from the corporations and the job
creators when those workers need to be
put back in line and they need to
appreciate the people who give them jobs
well you can take your job and you can
shove it up your ass
that's what the American workers should
be saying to people who don't appreciate
their labor [__] you take your job and
stick it straight up your a-hole all the
way up in there
all the way up in there and take your
[__] stupid ass expectation that we
should appreciate you because you don't
pay us what we're [__] worth
you can stick that up there too along
along with your [__] job
folks in capitalism someone will fill
the Gap I know it feels like oh my God
Tony these are American companies that
you're speaking against yeah I can't
believe that American companies aren't
[__] stepping in make sure the
American people get the fair [__]
share so this economy can get rolling
do you think do you think inflation is
some some sort of [__] is some sort
of thing that's just invisible to these
corporations no half the [__]
inflation problem is him gouging us and
not gouging us just from the prices
not gouging us just from the prices okay
because they're gouging us at the
[__] pumps their gouges at the
[__] stores
but they're gouging us on the acid too
when we as the American people the
working class what keeps profits in
their [__] Pockets do not get
our portion of the [__] GDP
our portion of the inflation
I don't know if you know this I don't
know if you [__] know this about how
this works inflation has made tons tons
of of rich white property owners in this
country and property owners in general
but mostly white people let's face it
rich white Property Owners wealthy
beyond their Wildest Dreams what do you
think inflation does
why do you think Rich [__] people put
their money in real estate why do you
think they do that the reason why is
because when money inflates the value of
cash goes down
but when money inflates the value of
property because the amount of money
goes up all their money's in that
property
so if you know if you know [__]
out there that are bitching about
inflation and they own a shitload of
property they own a shitload of real
estate they shouldn't be bitching about
inflation they got rich off inflation
they got [__] Rich it's the people
who don't own property
who only have the only piece of capital
they have to trade away
because they don't have a big [__]
they don't have a big goddamn Cash Cash
of of riches that their parents gave
them
they don't make [__] they don't make
[__] just gazillions of dollars a
year [__] on workers
they only have one thing one piece of
capital just trade away and that's their
[__] labor that's it they got just a
one thing time and their labor
and we realized that during the pandemic
when they told people oh no you gotta
stay working you're essential
you gotta risk your life for a virus
because you're essential and and those
essential workers went but I get paid
the lowest
what the [__] what do you mean I'm a sin
I get I get paid the least amount of
money and I'm essential if I'm so
[__] essential well then maybe you
should pay me as kind of a an essential
wage even companies who knew
that's what was going on during the
pandemic they knew that's what workers
would think because they it's not a
[__] secret
it wasn't a secret then
there was companies like Kroger Walmart
all kinds of big corporations that paid
their workers essential pay
because they knew they would lose their
entire Workforce if they looked at their
Workforce and said boy you're essential
but we're not going to pay you a single
extra dime more
they knew what would happen they
wouldn't have a [__] Workforce those
people would say well [__] you but what
I'm essential but you ain't gonna pay me
[__] you
there is a silver lining to what
happened in this country in 2020.
and you're seeing the results of that
paradigm shift now
there's one person in this country that
understands this
watched it happen and is instituting
policies to move that forward because we
are in a pivotal moment in this country
where we can absolutely change the
Paradigm in this country against
billionaires
and these rich [__] corporations I'm
not saying that there shouldn't be
billionaires and there shouldn't be rich
corporations out there that's not what
I'm saying and I'm saying that companies
shouldn't make profit and that we should
that we should have government takeovers
of entire Industries that's not what I'm
saying
what I'm telling you is is in this
capitalist system we are in a unique
moment in history where we can do some
trust busting
not only can we do some trust busting
but we can make sure that the American
working class gets their [__] portion
of the GDP
and there's one person one [__]
in this country that understands that
and he went and joined the UAW on the
picket line
and you know I don't say Joe Biden's
name a lot on this show I don't have to
because Joe Biden puts out his [__]
shoes every single morning and does his
job
that's why I don't have to talk about
him a lot here honestly if Joe Biden did
a lot of [__] that was really bad I'd
[__] say [__] against him and you
know I would you know I wouldn't hold
back I don't give a [__] if he's a
Democrat
but there's one thing I believe
about Joe Biden one thing I believe and
it's the [__] most important thing
not his [__] age
not not how fast he walks not how much
he exercised not if he's watched
shirtless on the beach
there's only one [__] thing I care
about with Joe Biden only [__] one
he gives a [__]
he gives a [__] about the American
working class
and that is the most [__] important
thing about him I don't give a [__] how
leftist he is how woke he is I don't
care if he's too Centrist I don't care
if he doesn't do this most socialist
policies
I don't care if he's too conservative or
he's or he's a commie I don't give a
[__] about any of that narrative any of
that talk none of it there's only one
thing that [__] matters to me
is that Joe Biden gives a [__] he gives
a [__] about the American working class
and it shows not just in his policies
but when he's out there in action
so you can take this [__] scumbag you
can take this [__] scumbag who would
love to bust every [__] Union there
is
and he would love to pay his workers
what he paid him 40 years ago because
he's a cheap piece of [__] and he wants
all the money in his pockets because he
wants to pretend to be part of the
oligarchy in this country you can take
this guy you can take this fat [__] and
you can shove him straight up your ass
with that job
that underpaid job that's where you can
stick it
[__] him and [__] you we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around I need an adjustments
how the hell we're rambling it
uh when I get in on
decent [__] wage for people in this
country I get serious I do not [__]
around and just one thing that I believe
that can actually stop a lot of this
delusion that's right I actually believe
that actually meeting people where they
are in this country and part of where
the people are in this country is most
people it doesn't matter their political
affiliation want to earn a decent
[__] wage and want to get paid what
they're worth
no matter what job they have what
industry they're in they want to get
paid what they're worth
and the media focusing on stupid ass
[__] other than those issues that matter
to the American people folks because
honestly that [__] matters
I mean are you having trouble going to
the grocery store and buying groceries
are you having trouble putting gas in
your tank are you having trouble paying
for all the [__] you need to pay for to
live and just a the lifestyle that you
want to live
it ain't Joe Biden's fault if you can't
do that
really is if you could earn a decent
[__] wage a lot of that goes away but
that issue is important to the American
people it is really [__] important
why do you think Joe Biden don't give a
[__] if they're talking about his agent
he'll go to the picket line
why do you think I'm so optimistic about
Joe Biden trouncing Trump next year
do you know how [__] important this
issue is this is the quintessential
kitchen table issue is people's personal
economy and let me tell you something
when you start talking about people's
personal economy
how much gets in their pocket
is like the first part of the
conversation
right
that's it
that's the first part of the
conversation is how much I'm making
because almost every American who works
their ass off 40 hours a week or more in
this country because they got to work
two or three jobs
knows how exactly how much they make I
mean to the [__] penny they know how
much they make
and the reason why they know it is
because they rely on every last single
Cent
and if you took someone and you're like
what's the one thing that would help you
out right now in your life making more
money
or the prices going down one or the
other I either need more money or need
the prices to go down because I'm living
paycheck to paycheck boy haven't we
heard that
and forget about the old language of the
democratic party and liberals in this
country forget about that talk
forget about that [__] you need to
get to the kitchen table
right you gotta get right in front of
the people where they are what matters
to them most
and what matters to people most on most
days
is a decent [__] wage they want to
make enough money to live the lifestyle
that they have
period
and a sentence
and the only way to do that is to try to
combat two things
two try to combat inflation
of goods and services
which sometimes there's not much help in
that
but sometimes there is
sometimes you can do things to combat
that which they have the by
Administration has done a good job of
getting inflation in the right direction
down going down
now what we need is Wages to go up
it will help solve people's personal
economy problem because the economy is
not bad right the economy's strong
that's the other thing that the media is
so full of [__] about they're like oh
well just try to tell the average
American that the economy is good the
economy is good it's just they aren't
getting the benefit because all the rich
[__] are taking all the money
their personal economy is bad
don't you get it that's what we learned
during the pandemic that's why
corporations and rich people are so
[__] scared that's why people are
looking at each other going let's
[__] strike [__] them let's get our
[__] money it's time we get our
[__] money
so get with the program media but
they're not they're not going to get
with it they're going to still talk
about Joe Biden and how old he is in
2016 it was lock her up and now this is
moved to hang Mike Pence and execute
General Millie the news media has not
yet figured out how to handle Donald
Trump he's not a normal candidate this
is totally abnormal and yet there is
that impulse that okay if um you know
he's the front runner we have to cover
him how how do you do you deal with
someone who lies this frequently or this
valuably or who poses such a threat to
democratic Norms do you treat him like
every other candidate and I would have
hoped that the news media would have
learned something from 2016 but I'm
afraid not because we have one network
after another that thinks hey if we can
get Donald Trump on our show that's a
big ratings get
even among a lot of broad swath of the
voters there's this belief that this
can't happen here because the thinks
that Donald Trump is doing they're not
exclusive to him this is how
authoritarians operate a Stoke violence
they corrupt elections they politicize
independent institutions they spread
disinformation they quash dissent and
they marginalize vulnerable communities
and we've seen this happen in other
countries we've seen Orban do it we've
seen Putin do it we've seen Ortega do it
and now we see it happening here because
it's the same language he's been using
for years against anyone who criticizes
him he assumes they're enemies of the
state and he's convinced millions of his
followers that people are enemies of the
state this is autocratic rhetoric who at
this point thinks he's just saying this
yes he will govern as a dictator and I'm
willing to submit that there's not
anyone else in the United States who's
asked more ex-trump officials the
question that I've asked them which is
what will happen in a second term I've
asked hundreds of them that question now
and the answer is pretty much Universal
he'll govern without restraint he will
govern with retribution in mind he will
jail his opponents he will abrogate the
U.S Constitution and what's astounding
is these aren't our words they are his
words but the media is like oh yeah but
Joe bidenold
literally literally this morning
when I when I was when I was
when I was watching while I was
listening to Morning Joe this was their
narrative Donald Trump is gonna lose his
business and it's bad for Joe Biden
literally that was what they were saying
not not in those many words but that's
what they were [__] saying
that this morning
the [__] Hitler wannabe is gonna lose
his business in New York because he's a
[__] criminal and he committed fraud
and asked the judge to rule on that and
the judge ruled that he committed fraud
and he's gonna have to sell off all his
[__] to make himself even
The Narrative still was
I can't believe Joe Biden can't it isn't
ahead of him in the polls that's what
they were saying
and that's what the [__] they want
that's what the media [__] wants
that's what they want they want this
narrative that Joe Biden's oh oh wow why
can't someone why why can't someone
challenge Joe Biden No Labels No Labels
No Labels No Labels is is gonna go
nowhere folks No Labels is gonna go
nowhere
it's gonna go nowhere
just like this impeachment pretend
impeachment
it's all [__] pretend
it's all pretend it's all [__] watch
watch this New York watch this New York
Congressman realize
what he has to do and what he has to say
to stay elected heard from some of those
on the far right saying that they will
campaign against you and other New York
Republicans who are in more moderate
areas if you choose to do that what's
your response to your fellow colleagues
who are threatening that bring it I I
mean give me a break look I'm in a
district that Joe Biden won by 10 points
there's 70 000 more Democrats than
Republicans you hear that
did you just hear that
there is a Republican representative in
New York in a district
that has 70 000 more Democrats
than Republicans Joe Biden won that
District by 10 points
by 10 points do you know what do you
know what Mike Lawler is not doing
he's not pretending to be manka
do you want to know why Mike Lawler is
not pretending to be manga because he
knows his district is not going to buy
that [__]
he knows that Trump being popular is a
[__] lie
it's a lie
the one of the worst [__] lies that
we've ever believed in this country one
of the worst lies that the media
actually believes if you want to know
the honest truth
watch as Mike explains why he can't
impeach Joe Biden or
or be Maga I was elected to be an adult
to be serious to be sober and to govern
uh and to my colleagues that have put
their own uh personal uh you know views
and uh you know position ahead of the
conference uh go right ahead you want to
come at me I'll take that fight any day
and Lawler is gonna have to take that
fight because he's in an uphow uphill
battle in this District no matter what
because Joe Biden won it
in 2020 by 10 points and Joe Biden and
Lawler knows one fact
Joe Biden's gonna be at the top of the
ticket
come November 2024.
and he he's gonna have to be nowhere
near
impeachment he's gonna have to be
nowhere near shutting down the
government
he's gonna have to be nowhere near any
of this nonsense
and really honestly Mike Lawler his best
opportunity
to win as a republican in that District
is to be against Trump and Maga do you
folks see what's coming
I keep telling you that the media is way
off the Mark here Mike Lawler
understands it
representative Lawler understands it
he gets it
he gets what I'm saying he knows what
I'm saying is the [__] truth
Joe Biden is gonna absolutely [__]
trounce Trump in 2024.
the only thing we have to do as the
pro-democracy Coalition is do what
democracies do best and battle at the
ballot
and take every [__] seat that we
possibly can everywhere every state
every County
every [__] house every Senate every
governorship we got to take it all baby
everywhere we can we have to have
movement in this country it is it is
[__] high time that the majority
ideology in this country [__] have
the reins of power and do what this
country wants to move it forward to set
serious policy and stop talking about
[__] Bud Light being gay and Hunter
Biden's dick
people are [__] sick and tired of
that trash and that [__]
they're tired of it
and Mike Lawler understands it
he's gonna have to get elected in a
district let me say it again
that Joe Biden won by 10 points and Joe
Biden didn't win by 10 points because
Joe Biden's just the greatest person on
Earth
that's the other thing Mike Lawler
understands here
Joe Biden didn't win that District by 10
points because Joe Biden is some sort of
God
it is because that district will vote
against Trump
are you listening to me Mike Lawler
understands in his district where he is
the congressperson of the Republican
party where Joe Biden won by 10 points
in 2020
he understands that that district is
going to vote against
Trump
and the only way for him to be on the
ticket and win when Joe Biden is at the
top of the ticket and Trump is at the
top of the ticket is to be anti-trump
follow the [__] bouncing ball and how
it operates it's not complicated to
understand why Joe Biden is standing
with the American working class on the
picket line
Joe Biden knows that Trump is not
pro-union he knows Republicans are not
pro-union he knows that Trump is not pro
worker he knows that the Republicans are
anti-worker
he knows they are
foreign
Lawler
they know this [__] they got it
that's how it works
speaking of bonance Tommy tuberville
and she's still talk are we still
[__] paying attention to this game oh
yeah yeah we are oh my God because he's
telling us how racist he is she's Christ
oh man I can't tell you how important it
is that Alabama
um decide to have a senator who's got
more than two brain cells
Tommy two two branches Tommy two brain
cells here let's let's find out why
Tommy tuberville didn't want the newest
chairman of the Joint Chiefs to be the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs it's kind
of funny I don't know what it is about
it maybe
he'll let us know but let's see if it
has anything to do with it I don't know
his white supremacy yes you've decried
what you've called a woke policy a woke
military Senator and you voted against
the confirmation of General CQ Brown as
the now chairman of the Joint Chiefs is
the new chairman woke no I heard some
things that he talked about about race
and things that he want to mix into the
military let me tell you something our
military is not an equal opportunity
employer we're look what what our our
employer
that sounds kind of weird I wonder where
he's going with this hmm he might want
to put his his pointy hood on for this
interview but let's see looking for the
best of the best to do whatever we're
not looking for uh uh different groups
social justice groups we don't want to
single-handedly destroy our military
from within we all need to be one it's
like a football team I coach oh oh oh
it's like a football team oh okay that's
the only thing this [__] idiot knows
anything about is if and he wasn't even
that great of a football coach you want
to understand his truth let me rewind
here if you noticed something about the
the newest uh uh chairman of the Joint
Chiefs let's see here is his picture
there right up here up top do you notice
do you know something about him hmm
I wonder why he thinks this chairman of
the Joint Chiefs is woke did you know
did you know that Trump appointed this
guy
to the Air Force
the commander of the Air Force this guy
right here this woke guy woke
woke as Tommy tuberville calls it woke
you know they always ask what is woke
what's woke what does woke mean right
and you know they've bastardized this
word so much that it's hard to tell what
it means but if you actually go back
if you actually go back and look at
where the the dialogue of woke or
wokeism came from
It came it came in the 1960s
in the Civil Rights Movement
if you if you want to do some research
you know your own research
you don't want to go back and look at it
maybe maybe you should look up what
group of people we're talking about
people getting woke and why they were
being woke
Leslie's got it Leslie's got it
yep sure does it means black
it means black I've been telling you
that for a long time since since Ron
DeSantis can't stop saying the word he
me it means black
that's their code word
that's their code word but listen again
to Tommy 2 review here voted against the
confirmation of General CQ Brown as the
now chairman of the Joint Chiefs is the
new chairman woke no I heard some things
that he talked about about race and
things that he want to mix into the
military let me tell you something our
military is not an equal opportunity
employer we do not want to hire woke
we do not want to hire black people
racist piece of [__] [__] Tommy two
branches
Alabama I know I know you have a long
history
I knew you have a long deep seated
of racism in your state but it's time
it's time to walk past that it's time to
get past that [__] and get rid of this
sumbitch [__] this some [__]
to act like to act to say [__] like this
that [__] black people shouldn't be
in the military that's what he's saying
I don't give a [__] how you spend it
he's not saying it outright but he's
he's whistling to the dog ain't he
ain't he
[__] him [__] Tommy two branches [__]
racist piece of trash
I wonder what he called his football
players on those great football teams
that he coached he's trying to tell us
the [__] we should do
about football you know governments like
football
everything's like football because the
football is all I know what
Alabama you should be ashamed of
yourself
hell speaking of dumb people in
government
here's bobert
you notice no one's sitting next to her
anymore
I don't know maybe it's
you think there would be a lot of a lot
of people sitting next to her you know
what I mean
when you're in yeah when you're kind of
in like a
a theater setting you think people want
to sit next to her I'm just saying I
don't know maybe not
oh she's such a [__] ladderpoolers
tree Crowder says let's listen to this
this diatribe against the Poor's they
hate the pores they hate the pores folks
the Biden Harris Administration
expansion of the welfare state abolishes
work ethic and promotes
a new generation of government
dependency
oh boy she just stopped short of calling
them welfare Queens didn't she but you
know what's funny she admits that she
she wouldn't be where she's at without
welfare let's listen
I've lived under government dependency
and I'm thankful that I have broke free
of that cycle
how the [__] do you think you broke free
of from that cycle you piece of trash
again I tell you the reason why the
reason why Joe Biden is going to trounce
Trump is because of [__] like this
do you think do you think the majority
of the American people believe that the
reason why Lauren bobert is where she is
because she broke away
from the social safety net or do you
think that most the American people know
the reason why Lauren bobert is where
she is is because
of the social safety net that we provide
for our country and we should we should
but we should not
we should not be dumb enough to elect
people who are ladder poolers
as Trey Crowder calls Lauren bobert
[__] ladderpoolers again folks
everyone was so upset that she was
jerking some dude off in in a Denver
theater I'm not so mad about that
you know what really [__] pisses me
off is that people elect this [__]
[__] and she does [__] like this
wanna pull away the social safety net
that put her standing in front of that
microphone
given my life experiences and developing
work ethic I'm oh oh yeah work ethic
working hard juicing the beetle huh
Lauren the [__] out of here with this
nonsense
as as if breaking away from the social
safety net
that made sure you could eat you little
[__]
and that you're that you had a place to
live you little [__]
didn't have something to do with where
you're at today [__] you [__] all the
way off
and again oh I I know everyone because
the memes are great the memes are great
it's [__] hilarious about the
Beetlejuice thing but honestly work
that's not the worst thing about her not
not in not not even the top thousand
worst things about her folks
this clip that I just showed you one of
the worst things about her
[__] peace
of trash she is and that's what makes
her a piece of trash you want to see
what else makes her piece of trash
you want to see what else oh she's a
[__] bigot okay well let's let's
let's hear that yod's highest ranking
trans official this delusional man
thinking he is a woman embodies and
espouses the wokism that causes that's
causing significant harm to our military
Readiness you know what causes problems
to our military Readiness when
Republicans stop uh I don't know what
what's what's the thing that militaries
need to operate is it money
I don't know maybe maybe a good a good
structure like you know making sure that
leaders are in their right spots that
the military and the dod needs them to
operate properly that might you know
organization that might work
who's stopping who's stopping promotions
at the military who won't pass who won't
keep the government open to pay military
people to keep us ready Lauren who the
[__] is it huh who is it
is it trans people oh Trans people
they're really preventing us to fund the
government oh my God it's horrible it's
you should see all those trans people
out there just stopping us Republicans
from funding the [__] military oh my
God I can't vote for the military
because trans people won't let me no
[__] out of here with this nonsense
you're making the excuse that you need
to make you bigoted piece of [__] to be
anti our military
and you're using trans people as your
scapegoat because there's one trans
person that you don't like in a position
that you don't like them in
and they're hurting the military huh
[__] out of here listen this is why I
yell and scream every day because people
listen to this [__] fool and they get
their minds all [__] backwards
[__] out of here with this [__]
your bigotry is what is holding up the
military here
dummy
Jesus
and Troop morale
the military shouldn't be focused on
this woke agenda and
combating climate change and oh oh my
God the military the military shouldn't
be doing anything about climate change
or or promoting a person who's qualified
to do their job because it makes me all
kinds of funny inside when I know that
oh that woman used to be a man it really
gets all up in my feels
as if it [__] matters and it's as if
the American people give two shits they
don't they don't folks they don't
believe this line of [__] I'm here
to tell you no matter what the media
tells you no matter what Lauren bobert
tells you no matter what polls tell you
the American people do not give a [__]
if a trans person is qualified to do a
job in the military and they are given
that job based on their qualifications
they don't give a [__]
oh yeah there's plenty of loud
[__] out there like Lauren
bobert who yell and scream their bigotry
into microphones
who make it seem that way but I'm
telling you there's just about as many
people who give a [__] about that is who
care about who Trump is and him winning
which it ain't that many [__]
percentage-wise it just ain't
and how in the [__] does Lauren bobert
think concentrating on one person's
genitalia in the military is is somehow
helping
get the [__] out of here with this
[__] no one get listen even if even
if you don't understand trans people or
people transitioning or gender
reassignment or gender in general even
if you don't understand it even the
people who don't
they still don't give a [__] if someone
who's qualified is doing the job that
they're doing
hmm what a [__] bonehead
but you know what what are you gonna do
I mean you know
they gotta show their bigotry because
it's popular amongst the bigots
right Mike Lawler the reason why Mike
Lawler isn't saying [__] like this
because he can't say [__] like this
or he won't get elected
when the tail wags the dog
when the tail Langs the dog knit it up
let's see what else do we have here oh
this is [__] great oh my God okay so
uh hang with the news about Taylor Swift
and hang with me here hang with me here
because we're gonna we're gonna do this
Taylor Swift thing I I didn't talk about
Taylor Swift much
um and I think Gabe talked about it
yesterday with you guys after this show
and Gabe's I think Gabe's gonna be doing
a show
after today
um let's see let me double check that
but he talked about he talked about
yesterday he talked about Taylor Swift
apparently
um and he was talking about it on his
show
oh where is he where is he isn't that
show here at the man to get get him on
this
the hell is going on okay well we'll get
back to that in a minute we've got a few
minutes before then
here's the thing
the Taylor Swift thing the thing that's
the funniest part about it and this
video is going to show it more than
anything
is
[__] like these broces like these
stoolies out there who are really upset
that Taylor Swift is dating Travis
Kelsey right and all these stoolies all
of them every last [__] one of these
people who are Travis Kelsey are sports
fans that do not like all these [__]
in cell white dudes they all every last
[__] one of them know who Taylor
Swift is right they all know who she is
and the reason why everyone knows who
Taylor Swift is is because Taylor Swift
is the most famous person on the planet
she might not be the most recognizable
right but she is the most famous person
on the planet
it is why every single one of these
idiots
who [__] hate her know who she is
because she's famous right
what they don't understand is that their
little reality that they built for
themselves this whole oh my Idols are
the people who catch a football which
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with having an idol that
catches or throws a football or bounces
a basketball or dunks a basketball or
hits a baseball out into the Outfield
there's nothing wrong with having those
Idols nothing wrong with it
but it is a little funny that Maga
particularly but also these white
in-cell you know Sports dually types
don't understand
that they're not going to be Taylor
Swift okay you're not you're not you're
manga is gonna go against Taylor Swift
what if manga is gonna boycott Taylor
okay all right but watch this video here
where this woman is it appears to be
talking to her husband
watch him as he realizes
get so close to realizing what is the
actual truth and he doesn't quite get it
watch it this is [__] great the news
about Taylor Swift and uh Kelsey is
going crazy right now
and uh but I think it's so cool because
it's like she's gonna help him
she's gonna like help put him on the map
okay so imagine what this guy's thinking
right this guy's thinking she's gonna
say something right and she says she
says listen Taylor Swift is gonna put
Travis gelsey on the map
watch his reaction to this this is
[__] fantastic this is what the
internet has been doing for the last
[__] three days four days really
since Sunday
yeah like it it doesn't need help
he he doesn't need help being put on the
mat right right oh my God oh my God he's
just realizing in that moment in that
moment
how insignificant
insignificant the reality that he has
built actually is
because in his reality in his world
all the people that matter to him know
who Travis Kelsey is right
they know who he is minor football fans
they know who that is
hey dude most people don't know who
Travis Kelsey is
most people listen to me most people do
not know who Travis Kelsey is
a lot of people do he's pretty famous
amongst people who watch NFL football
pretty well known there
most people though do not know who the
[__] he is
[Laughter]
Taylor Swift is so much more relevant
and so much more famous than Travis
Kelsey will ever [__] dream of being
and he can't get over it watch this
no he's Travis Kelsey the guy's like the
best tight end in football maybe ever I
don't think many people know who he is
[Laughter]
many people do not know who Travis
Kelsey is not only do they not knew who
Travis Kelce is they don't exactly know
who he plays for and they don't know
what position he's in I mean until last
weekend oh [__] ever Sunday oh man
Sunday man now everyone knows who Travis
Kelsey is who he [__] plays for and
what position he plays on that team all
of them know that now I wonder what it
could be since last Sunday why why in
the [__] does the entire world now know
who Travis Kelsey is what team he plays
for and what position he plays I wonder
what it could be
what is it what is it internet in cells
what could it be that has happened in
the last week that everyone now knows
oh man yeah a lot of people know who he
is
Travis Kelsey I'm pretty sure she's the
one that's like making his crew yeah
crazy right now
you're joking right no
he can't he he literally his brain is on
fire
his brain is on fire
here because he is realizing how
relevant
are irrelevant
his reality that he has built truly is
because this guy
this guy obviously believes that there's
nothing more important than football
there's nothing more important
than who is the tied in for the Chiefs
rather your rooting Forum or rooting
against them that's a real important
thing in that reality okay but he's
starting to realize
the only reason why people know who he
is
in the last week
is because
he's [__] Taylor Swift
that's right
she's the reason why he's famous now
I mean a lot of people knew who he was
who give a [__] about football like this
guy and all his [__] brosives right
that's why this guy's confused because
he has no [__] clue that there is an
entire reality outside his little
[__] fragile male privilege
no [__] clue
he's hit this is probably someone who he
loves who is trying to explain this to
him in the easiest way she can
that you live inside of a little
privileged box my friend
I don't I don't know see I had I had
this same experience several times in my
life realizing realizing that my ass
lives in a stupid little white privilege
especially male fragility box
living a little bitty box
and there's a whole world outside that
box
and that world
mortally different than the stupid
little [__] reality that you built
inside your little box
if we could just get these people
understand like this guy here to
understand the reason why
the reason why it is so important to
give a [__] on a day-to-day basis about
what's going on in this country instead
of just what's going on down on the
football field
maybe maybe just maybe we could [__]
get some people in this country
to vote in a way that would help them
out
holy actual [__] this guy did not have
any clue no [__] clue in that moment
until she pointed it out to him that the
only reason why anyone knows in the last
four or five days who Travis Kelsey is
is because of Taylor Swift it's not the
other way around dummy
oh my God it's [__] hilarious you're
joking nope not she's not you she's not
joking she's not joking nope not gonna
oh my god listen that's actually one of
the best clips that I've seen in this
whole thing
with Taylor Swift and Travis Kelsey and
not one of them appears in it
not one of those not Taylor Swift isn't
in the clip Travis Kelsey isn't in the
clip
and and you know what
it's one of the best Clips to describe
what's going on with the Taylor Swift
thing the swifties because that's
hilarious that Maga thinks they're gonna
beat her right that's [__] hilarious
that they think
they're going to beat Taylor because
Maga manga the reason why Manga is
really upsetted her and and really it's
this masculinity thing in this country
you know what I mean it's ill oh
manliness it's all about the mailing is
and masculinity
right like this uh Macho Man type [__]
continues to [__]
just lying to people really pisses me
off but you know this is that's that's
how it goes
with these idiots
but the reason why Manga
hates Taylor Swift and they don't want
to go to war with her which I'm
welcoming honestly I'm welcoming the
Maga cult trying to outdo the Swifty
cult
whoosh I don't know I don't know if
you've ever have you ever met like a
die-hard Swifty
I'm not talking about someone who knows
who Taylor Swift is like I know who she
is I've heard her music but I mean most
the time like if I heard her song I
probably couldn't point it out like that
that's a Taylor Swift song I mean maybe
a few of them
maybe a few of them
but the swifties know every [__] word
they know every album
they know every [__] place that she's
toured where she's been
they know every single in and out of her
shows
they know every single thing about her
social media her social presence they
know every single little thing that
there is to know about Taylor Swift all
of it
all of it
and if you think that you're gonna get
hundreds of millions of people all
around the world and in this country to
walk away from Taylor Swift
because of this and you're gonna win
this battle you people are as delusional
as the guy who just got schooled by his
wife of why Travis Kelsey is more famous
today than he was on Sunday
like literally in real time you watched
him come to the fact that the reason why
Travis Kelsey is so [__] famous this
week isn't because of a football he
caught is it because of a touchdown he
made is it because of a stat that he put
up on the board
one reason and one reason only Taylor
Swift
but this is what Maga [__] hates
about Taylor Swift
is she won't keep her mouth shut she
won't
capitulate she won't genuflect to
Fascism in this country she won't
[__] do it watch Taylor Swift comes
out against Trump I don't care if they
write that
I'm sad that I didn't two years ago but
I can't change that
I'm saying right now that this is
something that I know is right and you
guys
I need to be on the right side of
history and if he doesn't win then at
least I I at least I tried yeah here's
the here's the problem I just want to
read you what I wrote and I'm going to
try to start I just really want you to
know that this is important to me
yes I've read the entire thing and the
bottom line right now I'm terrified I'm
the guy that went out and bought Armored
Cars I worry for her safety as much as
anybody does maybe more
it really is a big deal
she votes against
Fair pay for women he votes against the
reauthorization of the of the violence
against women act which is just
basically protecting us for domestic
abuse and stalking stalking
she votes she thinks that that if you're
a gay couple or even if you look like a
gay couple you should be allowed to be
kicked out of a restaurant it's really
basic human rights and it's right and
wrong at this point and I can't see
another commercial
and see her
disguising these policies behind the
words Tennessee Christian values those
aren't Tennessee Christian values I live
in Tennessee I am Christian that's not
what we stand for
I need to do this I need you to just
I just need you to forgive me for doing
it because I'm doing it
and she did do it and she will continue
to do it
the other reason why they're terrified
of Taylor Swift not just this clip here
this is not the only thing that pisses
manga off about her she she posted one
Instagram post one one [__] Instagram
post and 35
000 people registered to vote
35 000 people she showed up at one
[__] football game folks one [__]
football game one she only showed up at
one football game
the women's jersey sales at the NFL went
up like 400 percent
one football game
she didn't do a commercial she didn't
like hey go buy jerseys
go buy women's jerseys she just wore one
she moved the [__] needle in this
country for the economy just just by her
tour alone
that's why Taylor Swift
terrifies these [__]
Taylor Swift is famous Beyond Your
Wildest Dreams
Taylor Swift is Rich Beyond Your Wildest
Dreams
Taylor Swift could live her life the way
that she would want to live and anyone
else would want to live and no one would
bother her for the rest of her [__]
life
Taylor could stop making music she could
stop appearing in public she could stop
posting on social media
and she could do whatever the [__] she
wanted to do for the rest of her life
and no one would stop her
because she is so [__] famous so
[__] rich
and she decides not to do that
she decides to not just not just stay in
the music business for her fans
she decides to stand up against
oligarchy in this country
she decides to do what some leaders do
and go to the picket line
she decided to do what some leaders do
and stay in the fight for the people who
need to be fought for
she has values she has [__]
principles
it's clear she hasn't lost those
I'm sure Taylor Swift is different now
that she's famous and Rich Beyond her
wildest dreams and Beyond Your Wildest
Dreams
and I'm sure she's different than she
was before that happened her life is
different for sure I mean you see her
dad standing there saying I'm the one
who bought the armored cars
terrified for Taylor Swift's life what
for because she's gonna speak out
against the presidential candidate
that means that he should fear for her
life are you listening to what he's
saying are you listening to why the
conversation is having the way they're
having it this was about the 2020
election folks this was before January
6th
they knew they knew how violent Trump
supporters were
they know
they knew then and they know now
and this is why Manga is mad this is why
this is why the stoolies are mad because
most stoolies let's face it most white
fragile incel men
our privilege is waning
hate Taylor Swift because they love
Donald Trump
because she's a woman
and she has power and not only does she
have power
it's unelected power it's gained through
Trust
of her fans it's gained their trust to
the American people because behind
closed doors
Taylor Swift is is believes in the
American people
and I believe
I believe that Taylor Swift understands
the reason why she's so goddamn famous
and the reason why she's so goddamn rich
and she gets to live the life that she
wants to live is because of her fans
and she's going to make sure that she
doesn't [__] lie to them she's going
to make sure that she's on the right
side of History she put it in this clip
it's perfect
it's what our country needs
we need we need people
who believe in the American people who
believe in the American working class
who believe in democracy
who believe in not ostracizing people
out of society who believe that women
should have the choice in their health
care and privacy who believe in Liberty
who believe in freedom and rights
and not only do we need those people we
need them to speak up
and that's what Taylor does and that is
why they hate her
not because she's gonna hurt Travis
Kelsey
or hurt the Chiefs or change something
about their [__] game oh she's
changing our game
they hate her because
she's a threat to the the patriarchy the
oligarchy the plutocracy
remember I showed you a clip earlier of
a wannabe billionaire
talking down to the American working
people
acting like they don't deserve a single
goddamn dime because they are not rich
this is a clip of a billionaire
doing the exact opposite
so you decide
you decide
do you know who Travis Kelsey was until
Sunday did you know
I don't think you did
I mean let your football fan then you
may have yeah I don't know I don't know
we are going to get Gabe Sanchez on here
in a minute I believe but I have a
special
a special birthday today there is a
special person out there to this show
who's been around with this show for a
long time and she does so much for the
show she does so much for you guys with
the library of democracy and over on
Discord she's our local librarian the
mighty librarian's birthday is today so
if you know the mighty librarian if you
follow the minor librarian anywhere
please wish her a happy birthday and
I've got to sing Happy Birthday to you
Happy Birthday to you so what I want you
to do is go wish the mining librarian
happy birthday everywhere follow her
where you can go to the library of
democracy
go to the library of democracy and
follow the library of democracy's
Channel over on YouTube it's very
important she's doing so much good work
over there letting you guys know all
kinds of resources that you can use to
engage in your democracy how to engage
what they're trying to do when they're
banning books make sure you tell you go
to the library democracy's YouTube
channel subscribe to it first subscribe
to it first and then on one of the
videos go leave her a great birthday
message that's what I want you to do
it's free it doesn't cost you a single
thing to support her on her birthday on
the library of democracy's YouTube
channel so thank you for that I don't
know if Gabe's going to join us here I
am where listen you're going to go to a
show he's going to have a show
um you joining doesn't seem like he's
joining does it
didn't seem like you joining we're five
minutes to the hour here Gabe Sanchez is
gonna do his what was that live it's
gonna be right after this show so don't
go anywhere don't go anywhere if you're
on YouTube You're gonna go straight to
game show now twitch is a little
different I don't know what's going on
on Twitch
I have no idea what's going on
twitch like it's it's kind of weird I
can't raid him is is people having that
problem you if you're on Twitch
I think if you're on Twitch
um right now something's not right about
rating because that's what it's called
on Twitch if you guys aren't aware
twitch is they have different terms for
it here on YouTube you just go straight
to the you just go straight to the video
on Twitch you gotta like go over
to the channel right now because it
won't let me do the raid as it's called
on Twitch
um and I'm not sure if it's his settings
or my settings but I can rate other
channels like we get a lot of sparklers
here so I'll send people like to to
Hal's Channel if he's if he's uh
broadcasting after mine or I like I like
to send the audience to a Hassan [__]
Hassan [__] believes
[__] that I don't he's he's way
different idea ideologically than I am
his ideology is totally different than
mine I mean we're still kind of on the
same side but I want you to go listen to
him so I sometimes I'll raid his Channel
or his waiting rooms for you guys to get
an opportunity on Twitch to go watch his
show
um or how now gay but for whatever
reason it won't let me send it over
there so if you're on Twitch you're
gonna have to go to Gabe's Channel
like manually we're gonna do like a
manual raid but on YouTube if you're on
YouTube the main Channel it'll go
directly there and speaking of the main
Channel and the up wire if you're on the
up wire listening right now I know a lot
of people listen on the Empire we are
going to stop broadcasting live to the
up wire soon
um and we're gonna only broadcast to
YouTube the main Channel twitch and
Facebook so make sure that you're
following us here on YouTube if you like
in the YouTube chat if you're on up wire
because the live chat is going to be the
YouTube live chat is going to be over
here on the main Channel we'll probably
broadcast there we just won't have a
live chat
so the live chat is going to make its
way over here to the main Channel on
YouTube so you're going to want to
follow the main Channel on YouTube if
you're on upwire and then you know to
follow me on Facebook to go to Twitch
the best thing to do is go to the Tony
michaels.com follow everywhere and
you'll see that stuff also I want to
announce
we're going to change how the audio if
you're listening to the audio right now
and you're wondering why was the show
broken in two parts well we're gonna do
that from now on we're gonna break the
show in two different parts on the audio
version so on Apple Spotify Google
wherever you download the audio version
which you should be downloading on any
of the directories that you like you
should download the show every single
day it helps us get in the rankings
um so that's important but it's going to
be broken in two parts now so don't
freak out we're gonna do the the 30
minute rant and one part and then the
latter part in another part so this is
part one part two with the audio
speaking of part one and part two I'm
part one this is or I'm thing one he's
thing two how's the new set going over
there I mean it would be nice if you've
got your microphone right your
microphones yeah yeah again no no you
got to turn it on I mean that would be
nice and you only got two minutes here
so like I'm killing time and then you're
gonna have to go over and then I Ain't
Gotta Throw it yeah there we go there we
go all right all right what are you
talking about today on your show
obviously got to talk about Trump gotta
talk about
do you like the poor in the news is
there something in the news
maybe there might be something in news a
little poor boy
uh and I'll probably cover a little bit
of Menendez because I didn't do that
before oh okay good yeah well get your
ass over there and talk about how
Trump's broke and Menendez is a criminal
okay all right all right we'll see we'll
see what's the interview what's the
interview oh boy Gabe Sanchez what was
that live with game Sanchez right after
this show don't go anywhere if you're on
YouTube and if you're on Twitch or
Facebook get over to the platforms and
if you're on Twitch you're gonna have to
manually rate him I'm gonna try to do
the raid I don't know if it's gonna work
but we'll try it so go over right now
but tomorrow
for this show the Tony Michaels podcast
two full hours same time
same [__] place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon